plus haute juridiction américaine la
cour suprême est compétente dans des cas
très précis
elle est habilitée à trancher en dernier
recours une décision prise au sein des
50 états du pays ou au niveau de l'état
fédéral
elle peut aussi être amené à statuer sur
la conformité des textes de loi et des
décrets présidentiels avec la
constitution
si la cour suprême peut être saisi ses
neuf juges ne sont toutefois pas forcé
d'intervenir dans un dossier
ainsi si donald trump fait appel à la
cour suprême elle pourrait accepter de
statuer sur les résultats électoraux de
certains états mais pour cela il faut
des arguments solides et que seulement
quelques voix séparent le républicain
joe biden il ne suffit pas d'aller en
justice il faut avoir de quoi le faire
et que cela affecte suffisamment de
votes si elle est saisie
combien de temps faudra-t-il à ses juges
pour se prononcer sur le scrutin
la bataille judiciaire pourrait durer
des jours voire des semaines la tendance
politique est crucial au sein de
l'institution
donald trump a placé ses pions avec
l'arrivée des me barre est comme juges
assesseurs le 27 octobre dernier set
républicaine opposée à l'avortement
succéder à la progressiste ruth bader
ginsburg en quatre ans donald trump a
nommé trois juges à la cour suprême en
accord avec la chambre haute
aujourd'hui six de ses neuf membres sont
des conservateurs
cette nomination peut être vu comme une
victoire à la fois pour le camp
républicain mais aussi sur le plan
personnel pour donald trump
cela lui permet d'asseoir son autorité
et surtout de lui donner un atout pour
arracher une élection présidentielle
dans le cas où les résultats seraient
très serré c'est en 2000 que la cour
suprême a été saisie pour la dernière
fois pour une présidentielle
il lui avait alors fallu plus d'un mois
pour statuer sur le scrutin opposant le
démocrate al gore aux républicains de
george w bush
sa composition était à l'heure dominé
par les couleurs républicaines